l'épidémie reprend du terrain sur la
pologne une semaine après le retour du
masque obligatoire
les mesures ont finalement été endurci
ce jeudi suite à l'enregistrement de
plus de 8000 nouveaux cas le premier
ministre matthaus moravie et ce qui a
notamment décidé de fermer les collèges
et lycées pour ne pas impacter
l'économie
les restaurants pourront rester ouverts
jusqu'à 21h et le nombre de personnes
admises dans les magasins et transports
publics sont seulement limité nous
voulons mettre en place des restrictions
qui vont nous protéger contre
l'expansion du coronavirus mais nous
voulons que dans la mesure du possible
l'économie tourne
nous nous sommes débrouillés avec le
govic 19 au printemps et nous pouvons
également le faire maintenant
nous gagnerons cette bataille mais nous
ne la gagneront que si nous sommes
solidaires et que nous appliquons
ensemble les restrictions en république
tchèque la situation devient de plus en
plus critique
possédant le plus haut taux de
contamination d'europe le pays bas
chaque jour son record quotidien de cas
confirmé ce vendredi la république
tchèque enregistré pas moins de onze
mille cent cinq nouveaux cas et 1283
décès de nouvelles mesures sont entrées
en vigueur ce mercredi
parmi elles la fermeture des bars et
restaurants ainsi que les institutions
éducatives pour faire face à cette
hausse de contamination romane primula
le ministre tchèque de la santé a tenu à
prévenir le personnel soignant des
difficultés à venir
nous devons préparer le système de santé
à accueillir de nombreux patients je
souhaite aussi remercier le personnel
qui a fait un excellent travail et
malgré l'afflux important
je veux aussi les encourager avant
qu'ils subissent cette vague
il faut continuer à travailler pour
libérer un maximum de lit comme je lé
déclaré nous avons doublé notre capacité
pour aider le système de santé le
gouvernement a aussi demandé à l'armée
de construire un hôpital de campagne de
cinq cents liée à l'extérieur de prague
en appel au médecin tchèque officiant à
l'étranger pour venir en aide au pays a
aussi été lancée